[Music]
today i'm
going to talk about feminism um
funny enough over the last few years
feminism has
taken such central stage in political
debates
and it hasn't been talked about for a
while because we're all rather obsessed
with
rightly so um the current pandemic and
larger political questions whether it be
about brexit or the economy
so the issue of feminism has sort of
taken a back seat
and um i want to look at the reasons why
i think the future of feminism is
something that we do need to talk about
and i think more importantly the future
of women's freedom is something that i
care a great deal about uh i think that
right from the off i'm going to come out
and say that
uh for me the future of feminism has to
be
a no future there can't be a future for
contemporary feminism as it currently
stands
um it can't carry on uh with the kind of
politics that's been running especially
for the last 10 years
whether it be from feminist campaigns
like the hashtag me2 movement
um or more centrally organized feminist
groups whether they be parliamentary
parties
or otherwise i think that feminism is
dead in the water i'm
not a feminist at myself and i wrote
about this in my book what women want
fun freedom
and an end to feminism which was quite a
long time ago it came out a number of
years ago
uh and you know made famous or at least
slightly made famous by mel
mel gibson was who i took my inspiration
from the book from but really because it
was trying to poke
a bit of fun at the sort of
uh religious nature of contemporary
feminism
at the moment you know the sort of
unequivocal expectation that women
should have to wear the f word um
as a label that that politicians feel
that they have to come out and state
that they are feminist celebrities
get more plaudits if they come out and
say that they have you know brandished
their feminist credentials
but actually um what i wanted to look at
when was writing this book and thinking
about feminism was
are most women feminists uh
and you know you can say what you like
about polling and say what you like
about
surveys they're often wrong but there's
have been
interesting numbers and data brought out
about the fact that very few women
actually label themselves feminists in
the uk anyway
it's somewhere between the 7 and nine
percent mark and that's coming from
surveys done by the fawcett society
which itself is a feminist organization
so stop your average woman on the street
and ask her what her political
identification is and it's
very unlikely that she'll say feminist
and
that i think is a problem i think that
contemporary feminism
uh as it stands is more likely to serve
the interests of a very small section of
society middle class women professionals
uh professional feminists i like to call
them people for whom
wearing that f badge that f word
uh gets them up and allows them to
socially climb
allows them with a wink and a nudge to
be accepted in the right kind of circles
but for the majority of women it does
very little other than you know become
something that
is on a pink glittery pencil case you
might buy your daughter
in primark or something that their
favorite celebrity might say when they
before they start their show and i think
that
part of the problem of this is that uh
feminism
has centrally become about fear the
politics of fear
and i'm going to look at three ways in
which that's that's come about
fear of work fear of sex and fear in
ourselves
and i think you know one of the things
that that part the problems of
contemporary feminism
is that while it seeks to portray itself
as
being about preventing fear for women so
we do have a lot of discussion around
what we can do to
make women more empowered to know what
language we can use
in the workplace or elsewhere to you
know make
women stronger to uh you know to protect
us against
negative or sexist stereotypes and
underpinning
a lot of the conversation around what
women what feminists seem to think women
need
is uh around a politics of fear so we're
told that
the world outside our four walls is
wrapped with
uh fearful things whether it be sexist
bosses
sexist partners sexist family members
the sexist man waiting outside the
corner shop
and also within our own homes that
actually that we are sort of brought up
shrouded in fear worried about our body
image worried about our sense of self
worried about whether or not we'll fit
in worried about whether or not we'll
fit in with our male
uh partners and relationships and all of
that i think there's a huge
amount of fear going on in the
in the politics of feminism ironically
at a time in which
the world is a far less fearful place
for women you know even in the last 30
years the kind of
changes that women themselves have made
in through political campaigns
and fights for freedom has meant that
really for women living in the west
certainly in the uk
there is very little to fear and so i
want to kind of look at why
given the situation we're in that women
have sort of actually never had it so
good
that we are expected to be afraid of
everything so i want to first
take a look at the fear of work
and fear in the workplace because this
is something that keeps coming up so
if you are a young woman about to go out
into the
workplace whether it be in office or
anywhere else the office is often where
it's
this kind of discussion centers around
which in itself might give you an
indication of how limited some of the
the scope of some of the politics of
feminism
is given that not all women work in
offices but sticking with the office
uh sort of example the first thing that
you're told if you pay any attention to
what your
uh life might be like when you're when
you go out into work
is this question of the pay gap you're
told that as a woman you are
categorically not going to earn as much
as men
that the odds are stacked against you
and that you know
essentially don't don't think about
trying to kind of be ambitious around
this because ever
you know there's sexism inbuilt into the
system
and when you try and pick apart gender
pay gap data you're
quite often told that you're sort of
denying reality that you are
um being sort of oblivious to to the
facts and obviously the
part of the problem is that the data
around this is very complicated and i've
just sort of tried to be a bit
piss-taking here by
pulling out several headlines and
showing that even amongst themselves
people who agree with the
sort of official feminist line that
women are that the gender pay gap is
real
that women are discriminated against in
the workplace they don't always agree so
we've got you know it's going to take
60 years to eradicate the gap 250 years
to close the gap
you know 99.5 years to close the gap
every year
it changes not in relation to any kind
of material reality
but because a lot of the time the stats
involved in uh
how you assess women's um place in
payrolls and
how you assess the way women are are
paid in comparison to their male
counterparts is always based on
averages and joanna williams does a
great uh deal of work on this
she's a a writer and commentator
pointing out the fact that
actually the things that don't get
talked about is the fact that women in
their 20s and 30s are often out earning
men but more are going to university and
that we're doing really quite well
the difficult part and the way the way
in which women do suffer when it comes
to pay
is when they begin to reach a period
when they want to have children
that's when pay differences come in in
terms of
and women not being offered the same
kind of full-time work or not being
offered the same kind of salary after
they have children but the idea that
simply
being a woman and entering the workplace
and this at the same day as a man and
you're being discriminated against
there isn't the data to show that at
least it's illegal
but there just is not the data to show
that so the question is why is this
something
that we're constantly told we should be
frightened of and then obviously the
other
massive thing that's been that's sort of
given women
uh the need to be fearful in the
workplace is this discussion around
hashtag me too which i'll come to a bit
when i'm talking about sex but
the idea of the office um around the
water cooler
you know if they even exist anymore
around the workbench that you should be
always on your guard for sexist remarks
from bosses
sexist remarks from colleagues that
women need to have policies instituted
zero tolerance policies
put in place in their workplaces to
prevent them from
uh having to deal with any kind of
negative behavior from
men and again this is a kind of a
completely out of touch uh picture of
the fact that actually
most women might in some cases
have to deal with negative behavior in
the office from men and women and from
all different kinds of hardships
but the idea that you would need a
patronizing policy
to prevent any kind of flirtatious
behavior or some of the things that hit
the headlines over the last few
years in relation to hashtag me too is
stopping drinking at work christmas
parties in case
people take advantage of drunk women
because
drunk women don't ever want to have any
fun in the christmas party uh
or that you need to have special in
policies instituted like chaperones
where if a woman is having an interview
with a man they shouldn't be left alone
she should be
given a chaperone and it's these kinds
of extremely patronizing actually in
some cases rather sexist
protective policies i'll feed into this
idea
that the workplace is somewhere that
women should really be fearful of and
should always be on their guard of
what i'm going to come to later is you
know talking about the fact of why that
is so negative because if you are going
into there's no one who ever went into
um you know a meeting about increasing
their pay
or getting a better role fit
frightful that their boss is going to
touch them uh you know
on the knee under the table ever got
anything out of that so constantly
filling women with
fear about these kind of interactions is
only going to limit their ability to act
as
as individual agents and as sort of
quote unquote strong
empowered women to continue watching
this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below
or visit iai dot tv for more debates and
talks from the world's leading thinkers
on today's biggest ideas